[Music]
maybe out of line asking logical
questions about a dr. Seuss story but I
gotta ask one that's been bothering me
since I was very very young what the
heck is a Grinch biologically I mean
he's a furry green monster that lives
alone in a snowy cave there seems to be
only one of him he hates everyone and
yet he still owns a dog according to the
poem he can slither like a snake through
the who houses and according to the
lyrics of you're a mean one mr. Grinch
at various times he's a crooked jerky
jockey a nasty Westie skunk and a greasy
black banana
I mean internets your guess is as good
as mine or I guess my guess is as good
as mine cuz I know at some point I'm
gonna have to be the one to answer my
own question aren't I huh it's lonely
being a theorist sometimes
[Music]
hello Internet
welcome to film theory the show that'll
warm the cockles of your heart and then
inspire you to look up what cockles
actually are one apparently they're
small bivalve molluscs and the reason we
say cockles of our hearts is because
somebody hundreds of years ago mixed up
the Latin word for snails with the Latin
word for ventricle and we just never
bothered to fix it anyway with ethically
compromised holiday of Thanksgiving
behind us it's time that we go straight
into Christmas mode tis the season for
nostalgic remembrances of advent
calendars elementary school pageants
pull the cringe and walking through the
aisles of Toys R Us rest in peace all
while being enchanted by things like
dolls with stretchy arms and
uncomfortable pieces of plastic that
will bruise the bejesus out of your
ankles but it's important to consider
that not everybody remembers those times
so fondly of course I'm talking about
the Grinch one of the most plainly evil
characters in all of the Western canon
sure I can get behind some anti heroes
who make questionable ethical choices
but stealing the source of joy from all
the hoo children in all of Whoville is
simply beyond the pale of course the
Grinch also has one of the most
memorable turnarounds of any villain
that I can think of when he brings
everything back to the who's and more
importantly has a very literal change of
heart to use the original source
material we should say that the Grinch's
heart moved three times now I'm not sure
what old Doc Seuss meant by three sizes
hearts don't come quite as standardized
as khakis so by the looks of that visual
representation the only Christmas
miracle here is if the Grinch's heart
doesn't crack a rib but the question I
have today is how much of this is a tall
Christmas tale and how much of it could
actually happen could the Grinch survive
his heart growing three sizes or is the
end of How the Grinch Stole Christmas an
awful lot like the middle of alien
was it really the Christmas spirit that
made his heart swell or is there
something else to blame is the end of
one of our all-time favorite Christmas
stories a tragic disaster instead of a
heartwarming tearjerker all coming up on
this episode of grinches Anatomy where
we're gonna need 50 cc's of theorizing
stat if we're gonna consider the
ramifications of the Grinch's heart
suddenly going where no heart has gone
before we have to first consider the
statement his heart is in we're told
right off the bat narrator believes the
reason the Grinch hates Christmas is
that his heart is two sizes too small it
might seem like that should be enough to
kill the Grinch outright but tiny hearts
are indeed a thing among human beings
since the Grinch hawks and stands
upright and owns a dog we are for the
sake of simplicity gonna compare him to
a human being when it comes to whatever
crazy heart condition he has small heart
syndrome is a relatively uncommon an
uncreated Lea named condition that
results in low oxygen levels in the
blood and a tendency towards extreme
fatigue even after normal levels of
physical activity research also shows
that having a small heart makes it
vastly more likely that the individual
will have chronic fatigue syndrome I
know I'm starting to sound a bit like
one of those minute long commercials
that come on during the price is right
but trust me that I'm going somewhere
with all this chronic fatigue syndrome
or CFS makes you feel constantly tired
puts you in a sort of mental fog gives
you sleep problems poor circulation and
makes you more sensitive to external
stimuli like noise we can see from his
general Grinchy shape that the Grinch is
definitely skipping leg day and arm day
and AB day so we definitely have
evidence pointing to fatigue and
lethargy and all that stuff about poor
circulation which would cause cold hands
and feet may explain why the Grinch
bothers to wear shoes but neglect pants
the real clincher here though is that
not only does chronic fatigue syndrome
factor into the Grinch's small heart it
also perfectly explains why he hates
Christmas in the first place his
rationale is mentioned casually at the
beginning of the movie
No
if the Grinch has trouble sleeping in
the first place due to his chronic
fatigue syndrome which also then makes
him particularly sensitive to noise I
gotta say that I kind of feel some
sympathy for the poor guy not only is he
a societal outcast who lives by himself
in a snowy cave but he's got himself a
chronic condition and the only people he
ever gets to see love to make a big
hootenanny and make his life even more
miserable with their cheerful sounds and
it's not like he's trying to kill all
the Hoos or burn down Whoville or steal
their stuff on a regular basis one time
on the one day of the year he just
wanted to not be made miserable and have
his health problems exasperated and all
of a sudden he's this terrible person
for life call me Grinch Pat but I think
that the Grinch's actions are actually
kinda defensible I mean trust me as the
father of an infant son I have a
newfound understanding of the
desperation for a good quiet night
asleep
whatever that is I can't even remember
anymore and let's not forget that the
Grinch doesn't even succeed at stealing
Christmas he feels guilty and gives it
all back why do we hate this guy I mean
they don't make super villains out of
people who are guilty of attempted
murder so why is this guy the worst when
his only crime was attempted holiday
theft could it be that the Grinch is
actually the hero of Christmas no
clearly not
and even if he was that would be for a
very different episode so the TLDR is
that the Grinch has chronic fatigue
syndrome and a teensy ticker with the
elevated heart rate and blood pressure
that goes with it so what does it mean
for his prognosis when his heart
suddenly plumps up like me after three
rounds with Thanksgiving turkey well it
depends on what's going on but the most
likely explanation is that the Grinch
has had a heart attack and a subsequent
meta cardial rupture I know old cartoons
are very scary especially from a medical
perspective so what does all of that
mean well when this happens it means
that one of the valves in his heart
bursts open letting all the blood that's
very carefully regulated in and out of
your heart rush in until the pressure
equalizes and that might sound like an
extreme leap for a green Christmas
monster but tons of details in the story
line up with this
a diagnosis let's start with the fact
that again due to his chronic fatigue
syndrome the grinch is indeed pretty out
of shape even if that big Grinch wagon
is doing just fine
and yet all Christmas night he's been
running around from house to house
climbin up and down chimneys javelin and
Christmas trees around all while
carrying the presence of the entire town
with him his muscles are going to be
exhausted and that includes the muscles
in his heart but then we get the
clincher the sequence when the Grinch is
led almost runs over the top of Mount
crumpit and he sees the error of his
ways he finds the who resilience
charming and so he Sprint's up the rest
of the mountain a mountain we are
expressly told is 10,000 feet high up
the side of Mount grabs the sled loaded
with about eight tons of presents and
then his heart grows three sizes to the
point that it looks like it should
explode out of his ribcage while this
may all look like he's just moved by the
spirit of Christmas in reality he's just
moved by a lot of neurotransmitters hmm
nothing to take that magical feeling out
of the holiday season like explaining it
away with biology I know how to have
myself a good holiday you see when the
Grinch notices the sled starting to go
over the top he's gonna have himself a
moment of panic you know that sinking
jumpin feeling in your stomach when you
realize a big problem where you have
yourself a bad surprise that feeling is
adrenaline and noradrenaline coursing
through your body high levels of those
hormones are the ones that are gonna
give you that dizzy excited feeling
while also allowing you to run faster or
suddenly gain super strength in a moment
of extreme need those are the stories
they hear about parents lifting cars off
their children people racing long
distances to escape danger or in our
case rescuing a town full of Christmas
presents from the edge of a cliff in
this moment he has to quote the movie
unfortunately the other thing that a
large sudden spike of those hormones can
create is a massive heart attack in
particular the sudden stress may cause
arterial plaque to dislodge and clog up
the heart with a blood
this itself isn't gonna cause the
Grinch's heart to explode but it does
give us a pretty good explanation for
what we see in the cartoon mighdal
cardio ruptures which caused the heart
to swell up almost always occur in the
aftermath of a heart attack a
cardiologist from Johns Hopkins named
dr. David Cass actually discussed what
could have caused the Grinch's heart to
grow three sizes quickly and one of his
possible diagnoses was a ruptured valve
though he ultimately rules it out by
saying that the Grinch wouldn't have
felt so good when it was happening
you're not gonna be handing out lots of
presents and being cheerful so that part
didn't really fit so much but let's
consider how the Jim Carrey version of
The Grinch reacts when his heart is
growing three sizes roll the tape
[Applause]
I don't know about you but it looks like
he's having some sort of coronary up
sewed to me but even if you're bothered
by the fact that the Grinch in the
animated version isn't having any kind
of visible trauma that doesn't mean that
he hasn't had a heart attack some
studies indicate that as many as 45% of
people who have had heart attacks don't
realize that they've actually had one
even the Grinch's sudden warming towards
the hoos it may be evidence of this
heart attack the lack of blood to the
brain during the heart attack sometimes
causes feelings of euphoria for the
sufferer so while there is no Grinch
doctor on the scene to confirm in the
moment the fact is that there's a high
likelihood that the Grinch's heart
wasn't receiving jolts of holiday joy
and Cheer it was receiving jolts of
adrenaline that overloaded his systems
and literally caused his heart to
short-circuit so then what happens
well now the Grinch's heart is blowing
up like a balloon but he'll probably be
fine Wright's Christmas spirit and all
that well it depends on how severe the
situation is but it ain't looking too
great up to 82 percent of people who
experienced some form of cardiac rupture
will die within two weeks if it isn't
noticed and treated immediately
if the rupture is severe enough that it
breaks through the wall of the left
ventricle and judging by the visuals
that heart is breaking through every
wall that's remotely near it the
mortality rate jumps up to 100 point
zero percent thanks by the way
researchers for including that point
zero in their for emphasis
anyway is shaken the Grinch is almost
certainly dead within hours or days of
the movies ending even if you refer back
to the book you see him carving the
roast beast at the end but he's just as
dead as the Beast on his plate because
there is no chance that he sees another
holiday season so what we learn here
today friends quite simply that
Christmas cheer is a deadly thing and
matpat is the biggest Scrooge of them
all but you don't have to take my word
for it the answer has been hidden since
the very beginning just look at the
lyrics - you're a mean one mr. Grinch
your hearts a dead tomato splotched with
mouldy purple spots dead tomato with
purple spots
oh yeah it was there the entire time
you're a mean one mr. Seuss but hey
that's just a theory a film theory and
did you notice the subtle nod to my new
headphones in this theory it wasn't just
jamming out to some radical holiday
tunes well I wrote this episode Mannheim
Steamroller Christmas take me away these
are actually my new go-to headphones
from Dolby that particular about all my
technology but as a guy who spends all
day listening to youtube videos and
doesn't show that's entirely voiceover
and has to watch a lot of movies for his
job audio is the thing that makes a huge
difference for me for this episode Dolby
offered to sponsor us and asked if I
wanted to try out their new never before
tried Dolby dimension headphones
Christmas present alerts they literally
hand-delivered these things to me
because they weren't released to the
public yet I wasn't even allowed to let
other people in the office see these
things but let me tell you they are
incredible now that they've officially
been announced and I can actually show
them to people in the public I wear them
every day I take him on road trips plane
rides basically I just live in these
things now and the difference between me
being so excited about these headphones
and less so about headphones I've worn
in the past is a feature that you would
never expect it's actually one that
allows you to choose how much ambient
noise you hear in the headset it's
called Dolby life mix if I'm working
with other people on a theory or I need
to be able to hear a video and also hear
someone talking at the same time I can
just adjust the headphones that I can
hear both completely clearly it's insane
the headphones take voices from the
outside and amplify them based on my
preferences directly into my ear so I
can hear exactly what's being said well
I'm still immersed in what I'm watching
or listening to then if I want total
noise cancellation like on a plane where
if Jason's talking to me because lord
knows I don't want to hear Jason talk I
can just DoubleTap the ear and poof all
that noise is gone no more one headphone
on one headphone off which has literally
been home listen to headphones for years
and it kind of goes without saying but
the sound in these things is incredible
I mean it's Dolby they are the company
who's been doing movie beer so
systems for years and they designed
these things so you feel cinematic sound
in the headphones so whether you're
watching The Grinch nailed it holiday
episodes on Netflix or avoiding your
family with lots of single-player video
games you're bingeing smarter you're
getting the best sound quality in the
world with headphones that feel great
around your ears
all while not hearing anything else
around you in the process unless you
want it to so a huge thank you to Dolby
for my early Christmas present of these
amazing headphones and for sponsoring
this video supporting the show and
allowing us to buy one more lump of coal
for Jason if you're interested in
learning more about these amazing
headphones which are wireless and
actually make your life easier and
actually help you retain friendships
longer because people aren't shouting at
you trying to get your attention check
out the link in the description to see
him in action on their website or heck
if you happen to see a pair in the
stores try it out there is nothing quite
like trying these things out in person
it is a surreal experience I love these
things I know you'll get a kick out of
them especially if you care about high
quality audio for your entertainment
alright now if you excuse me I need to
go finish tabulating Disney debts see
you next time